so
we're going to start off today with some
introductions of the teaching team
that's me
anand i'm a fourth year phd student in
computer science
i work with professor andrew ing on
machine learning and
applying machine learning to different
problems
mostly in healthcare we also have
a wonderful team of teaching assistants
you'll meet the rest of them through the
quarter in office hours and such
okay so the goals of this course what do
we what do we
what are the goals in this course so by
the end of the course
you will we want you to be an expert in
machine learning which means
you understand the internals of how
machine learning algorithms work
not just using them but understanding
what's happening inside the algorithms
that's the main i would say goal number
one of this course
goal number two is to enable you to
build machine learning applications
which means having a good understanding
of what algorithms to use and which
scenarios
how do you how do you
decide whether a given problem is a good
machine learning problem not all
problems
are good machine learning problems and
once you know that a problem is a good
machine learning problem how
do you treat it as a supervised learning
problem unsupervised learning problem
we'll go through all those things
right and the third goal is also enable
you to be able to start doing machine
learning research
which means making you familiar with a
lot of the terms and concepts
that you will encounter if you pick up
and read a machine learning research
paper
so those are the uh the top three goals
for this course
prerequisites so um
machine learning is is uh part
mathematical and part
computer science in the sense it
requires
it's really the culmination of both
computer science and um
and and statistics so you will need to
have
basic computer science uh principles uh
you need to know them for example
you need to know what is bigger notation
right you need to uh kind of understand
what's
you know what's computation versus
what's memory you know basic computer
science principles
you'll need to be comfortable writing
non-trivial
uh programs with python and numpy
it would be great if you're comfortable
with recursion you know some of those
uh some of the ideas from recursion will
be useful when you're
translating um algorithms to kernel
methods you know we'll go
into detail about them later so um you
know
we we will assume that you are all of
you are
comfortable writing programs especially
in python or
at least be willing to put in the time
and effort to uh
pick it up the other big um
prerequisite is probability
you should have taken some kind of a
probability um
course in your you know academic history
so far
so concepts like random variables
distributions
should be you know you should be pretty
comfortable with them
you should know what's the difference
between a random variable and a
distribution you know
they're you know they're distinct things
then you should know already what what's
what's
uh what they are you know things like
expectations we'll be using all these
concepts
very liberally throughout the throughout
the quarter
the last prerequisite is uh linear
algebra and multivariate calculus
so you should already be comfortable
with things like
gradients and hessians you know you
shouldn't be seeing them for the first
time you should you should be
comfortable with
these concepts already uh
and and you know things like eigenvalue
eigenvector um
as well
so what about the honor code so
you are strongly encouraged to form
study groups
in fact i would say forming study groups
is a key key step for being successful
in this course
especially if you're not so comfortable
with the prerequisites
please do form study groups and you know
work together in study groups
however you should still write up your
homeworks and write up your code
independently
right so it is fine to discuss and
you know work on solutions together and
once you're done with your study group
meeting put aside
all the material that you used during
the study group and
independently from scratch you know
write up your homeworks by yourselves in
your own words
you know please do not refer to you know
the material that you used
in your study group session while
writing up the
writing of your your homeworks right
another important note is that it is in
violation of the honor code to refer to
homeworks and solutions from previous
years whether they are the official
solutions
uh released by this course or solutions
written by some other students in a
github
or whatever so it is against the honor
code to
refer to um solutions from the past
and we are very serious about the honor
code and uh
though we will you know um
we we will not actively look for honor
code violations we trust that you will
be
you'll be following them
so the course structure there are three
homeworks
each homework will be about two weeks
long
and each homework will will count
towards about 20
of your final grade and there will be a
final exam
it will be a take-home final exam uh the
reason it's a take-home is because you
need a computer
uh to to do your final exam there'll be
some
code uh more details on that you know
towards the end of the quarter
uh but it's going to be a take home
final exam very likely a 24-hour take
home final exam
um we haven't yet decided what's what's
the exact start
of that when the exam will start but
it's going to be a final exam during the
finals final slots
logistics so the course website is
on it's it's up it is cs229.stanford.edu
on the course website we have the office
hours calendars
the course calendars there are two
calendars up there one is for all the
office hours
when when each ta is holding their
office hours and
and where exactly and
the deadlines are part of the course
calendar
so we can have a quick look at the
course website
anyways it it's not opening over here
anyway so the
yeah you can look up the course website
uh on the course website there are
three big buttons as soon as you open
them you know one one button is called
syllabus
um let me see if i can
there you go okay so you have three big
buttons the syllabus
linked to piazza and and um the
calendars
so on the calendars there are two
calendars first one is the
office hours you can you can click on
this and add it into your google
calendar if you wish to do so
um but
the exact office hours of every ta is is
uh is out there and if you scroll
further down you'll see the course
calendar
basically we are in this lecture right
now and
we'll find details about when each pset
is out when each pset is due
all the deadlines are in the course
calendar so
if you are you could you could just add
this to your you know your personal
calendar to keep track of the deadlines
um and then we have the syllabus page
so on the syllabus page um we have a
collection of topics
that we're probably not going to cover
all of these but we are going to cover a
pretty big subset of these topics
and further down um here is going to be
a lecture by lecture
of what we are going to cover in each
lecture with the corresponding
slides or you know notes corresponding
to that lecture
and and the syllabus page uh the
this will be updated through the quarter
depending on what what the actual what
the actual progress we make is
right and piarza forum so all of you
should have
um all of you should have received an
invite to piazza already
if not click on the piazza link and
enroll right away
piazza is probably the most important
most important platform for the course
in terms of logistics because all
announcements will be made on piazza
the homeworks will be released on piazza
and you know
anything that you need to know in terms
of you know the final exam logistics
all those details will be announced on
piazza so please
sign up on piazza and and you know and
monitor it
great scope all the submissions will be
done on great scope
if you if you haven't used great scope
before
you know spend a few minutes to get
familiar with it
um the homeworks will be uploaded by you
into gradescope directly and we will
grade them on gradescope
um again for gradescope also you should
have
received invites by now if you have not
received your gradescope invite
you know create a private pr supposed
so uh in terms of any questions that you
have
through the quarter your first
your first destination will be piazza
if it is uh any a question related to
the course content about the course
logistics
create a question on piazza it's where
it's very likely some others may have
already created a similar question so
you can
you can either if you know the answer
help them out or
if you uh if you don't find the question
posted there
if it is a question that is specific to
you in the sense
for example if you're not able to you
know submit a homework on time and you
know that upfront and you want an
extension
things that are specific to you or if
you have an oae letter
create a private pr supposed you know
things that you don't want the rest of
the class to hear about
um if there are things that you want to
uh
if there are things even beyond that
that you want to
say for example just let me know um and
not even let the tas know just send me
an email directly with the word cs229 in
the
in the uh in the subject
so that is about the logistics any
questions on the logistics
i'll take that as a no
ok moving on
all right so what is machine learning so
the term machine learning was coined by
arthur samuel in 1959
and one of the very early programs that
that kind of got people interested in
machine learning
was a checkers playing program written
by arthur samuel
so it was a program probably most of you
know what
checkers is it's it's a two-person game
there is uh
a checkers board that looks like a
chessboard and you have
white and black pawns it has certain
rules
so arthur samuel wrote a program um
in a few years before 1959 and it became
popular in 1959
where the program would learn to play
against itself without any
any any kind of strategy being
explicitly programmed into it
right it learned to play by against
itself and it improved
its you know game playing performance as
it experienced more and more games
against itself
and eventually it learned to play
checkers
better than you know arthur samuel
himself i don't know how good a player
he was to begin with but
it got pretty good by just self-play
there was no
there was no strategy coded in by arthur
samuel into the program
only through experiences the program
learned to
play better and that was kind of the
um the event that kind of sparked
interest widespread interest in machine
learning
a more common definition by tom mitchell
he's a professor at cmu
is machine learning is the study of
computer algorithms that
improve automatically through experience
experience is is a loose term
what do we mean by experience most of
the times by experience we mean
prior data right examples from the past
where the machine learning algorithm
itself is a very generic um template
algorithm you don't
and you just you feed the algorithm data
from the past what you call as training
data
and the algorithm analyzes the data
that's given to it
and you looking for patterns in the data
the the algorithms improves its
performance at whatever task it is it is
uh
designed to operate on so the the key
here is data
or experience from the past that that
distinguishes machine learning from
other fields right
machine learning is also related to the
field of artificial intelligence
so ai is a much broader term and we see
the terms ai and machine learning being
conflated a lot of times you know
especially
in the news and media but strictly
if you look at the definitions of ai
and the definition of machine learning
machine learning is a subset of ai
right ai is a much broader field
ai is about um it's about building
programs
where the programs operate at the level
of performance of of say a human being
for example
again that's a very loose definition of
ai right so ai
is um is a broader is a broader
definition and it
deals with algorithms that perform at a
cognitive level
similar to a human being machine
learning is one approach of how to
implement such programs for example you
could implement an ai program
that does not look at any kind of
training data you just use
your smarts and write up a you know a
very smart program that that works
really well and
behaves as you know at the level of
a human in terms of performance and
that's still ai
but that's not machine learning in
machine learning
data is the key you look at past data
use it as a training set
or you build a simulator from which your
program can kind of um
build experience by interacting with its
environment and
that program which is looking at data or
which is looking you know which is
getting experience and some kind of a
simulator
improves its performance over time
that's machine learning that's one way
to
make your programs intelligent
however most of the attention recent
attention
in artificial intelligence is due to
machine learning
right artificial intelligence has been
around for a while machine learning has
been around for a while
but some of the recent advances in
machine learning
has made machine learning very
successful and therefore
the interest in artificial intelligence
is is kind of reinvigorated again
and even within machine learning there
is a specific
um a specific type of machine
learning called deep learning which has
actually seen the most
advances recently so it's it's uh
it's good to have this clear picture of
ai which is a much broader field which
is which is
dealing with programs that operate at
a similar cognitive level as a human
being
right it does not ai does not tell you
how to
implement such programs within ai
machine learning is a subfield which
which prescribes
one way to implement such programs
that's basically look at prior examples
and and
and learn from examples and even within
machine learning
there is a subfield of machine learning
called deep learning uh which uses
something called neural networks which
we will see
later in the course and that that has um
that's this the the field that has made
a lot of progress in the last five to
ten years
okay so here are some examples of where
machine learning has made a lot of
progress
so computer vision and image recognition
um
this was um this is a field that has
probably undergone
the most progress in the in the recent
years
there is a famous data set called
imagenet a computer vision data set
and there is a kind of model called the
convolution neural network
which together you know more or less
revolutionized computer vision
and this is all recent you know since
you know after
2012 and 2015 you know within the last
last decade
and it has also um significantly
improved autonomous driving
where you know machine learning
techniques are used to sense
where you know um pedestrians are where
the stop sign is where the traffic
lights are
um and it it is you know um it's a key
component for
for autonomous driving
machine learning has also significantly
improved speech recognition
uh and and and things like you know
it has made and it has made possible
things like voice assistants like you
know
apple siri or um the google assistant
etc
language translation so google translate
now uses
machine learning or from what we know
from what google tells us
it uses uh deep learning and in fact
there was also a paper from facebook i
think last year
which does unsupervised translation
which means just give it a corpus of you
know a whole bunch of
you know english of english sentences
and english documents and just give it a
whole bunch of
for example french documents and just by
looking at them where
it was the algorithm was never told what
is a matching english
and french statement but just looking at
two different corpus
it learned to translate sentences from
one language to another
and similarly with google translate they
had this um
they had this paper a few years ago
where
they built a single model that could
translate from
various pairs of languages and that
model
automatically learned how to translate
from
new pairs for which it had never seen a
training example before
those are examples in language
translation you know very exciting
exciting field there's also a lot of
progress happening in reinforcement
learning
or deep reinforcement learning and most
of
the progress there has been in game
playing like for example
mind over the last few years they built
um
reinforcement learning models that could
play atari games at the level of humans
so you you feed the model the pixels
from the display of an atari game
and just by looking at the pixels of how
how the game looks
the um the agent will you know controls
different actions and
the agent learned to play atari games
at a superhuman level across a whole you
know across
30 40 games and also alphago until very
recently
go is another board game and it was
widely considered to be extremely
difficult to play because you need a lot
of strategy a lot of planning
and um after chess was kind of
um conquered by by by
computer programs in in in the 80s and
around the 1980s go was then you know
thought of as you know
the next big uh board game that's really
hard to to kind of beat
and you know um alphago again you know
was was built by google again
you know which which plays better than
like the world's top go players
those are some of the recent
progresses and some preview into the
course what we'll be doing um
through this quarter so we're going to
look at
different supervised learning algorithms
unsupervised
deep learning algorithms some learning
theory and some reinforcement learning
so most of the time will be spent on
supervised and
unsupervised and a good amount on
learning theory and maybe a little bit
on reinforcement learning theory
so in supervised um learning
we're going to look at problems and
classify them
as you know regression problems versus
classification problems
what are regression problems when the
output of your machine
is is some kind of a real valued output
for example if you're trying to predict
the wind speed tomorrow
at you know at stanford and you're going
to build a machine learning model to
predict the wind speed
based on today's weather conditions as
the input
the output is going to be a real valued
number some you know kilometers per hour
or miles per hour so that's a real
valued number
so that's uh for example a regression
model um
classification model uh for example
if the output is binary or some kind of
a class will it rain tomorrow
yes or no right that's a classification
problem
given to race conditions if you're on a
predict you know whether it's going to
rain tomorrow
the answer is yes or no
and you can you can classify machine
learning
algorithms in in along many different
dimensions
as generative versus discriminative
probabilistic versus non-probabilistic
so any given machine learning algorithm
you can kind of place it on this hyper
cube of all these dimensions
and kind of taking a step back what is
supervised learning supervised learning
is a kind of machine learning
technique where the training data that
you have come in pairs
each pair has an input and an output
right an input is what you feed into the
machine learning algorithm
and the output is what the machine
learning algorithm should
output right so and that's called
supervision because for each example
you're telling the algorithm what the
right output is so that's the
that's where the supervision comes in in
unsupervised learning
algorithms you are you give the
algorithm
some data there is no explicit
supervision and you just ask it to
look for patterns or structure
interesting structure in the data and
the output
of your algorithm is that interesting
structure or you know
interesting pattern and again we kind of
classify unsupervised learning
algorithms as those that look for
clusters versus those that look for
subspaces
you know it's fine if you don't fully
understand these terms now just giving a
flavor of what's to come
in the rest of the quarter and deep
learning
is what's also commonly called as
representation learning where
the deep learning can can um can kind of
plug into
can you you can view deep learning in a
supervised setting unsupervised in a
reinforcement
setting etc where you're trying to learn
representations of your data
whereas in non-deep learning approaches
you are manually feeding in what the
right representation is
for the supervisor and supervisor
reinforcement learning algorithm
whereas with deep learning you're you're
letting the
algorithm itself learn the
representation as well along with the
final task
and then we'll cover learning theory
super important concepts of you know the
bias variance decomposition
bias variance trade-off generalization
and uniform convergence why do we expect
a model that was
trained on this training set to even
perform
you know with any level of accuracy when
you when you start using it in the world
when you put it to production because
you trained it on this specific training
set
now why do you expect this model to work
well in the real world you know
questions like that we're going to
answer them
in learning theory and that's probably
the learning theory is probably
the the the part of the course that that
makes this course interesting in the
sense you learn
principles that are common across
learning algorithms you know
common across learning algorithms that
have not yet been invented
right you know the the foundational
principles of why machine learning works
and then we'll spend some time on
reinforcement learning as well though
not a lot
so here's an example of a supervised
learning
algorithm image classification so these
are
examples of few images of handwritten
digits
this comes from a very famous data set
called mnist
where the input is a set of pixels you
know i think this
by is pixels or some some resolution
like that
and uh they are black and white images
uh in fact they are grayscale images
um where you you have the pixel value at
each location you feed the set of pixels
um
as input to some learning algorithm and
the output of the learning algorithm
is going to be is going to be a
one-off uh digits one through nine or
zero through nine you know it has ten
it's it's a a multi-class classification
problem so the output is it's
it's a classification but not binary
it's one among 10 classes
and you want to learn a machine learning
model
given this training data which which
is able to which is able to predict what
the handwritten digit is
for you know digits it hasn't seen
before
in fact you will be doing
you'll be working on this data set and
implementing a neural network to
to build a handwritten handwriting
digit classification in one of your
homeworks
okay so unsupervised here's an example
of
um an unsupervised uh learning so in
this example
uh it's what's commonly known as the
cocktail party problem
so imagine there are n speakers in this
case assume there are two speakers who
are in a cocktail party just the two of
them
and there are two microphones that are
placed in the room
at you know some some specific locations
now um the two microphones are recording
what the two speakers are speaking
and each of their recording is some
mixture of the
the what the two speakers are saying
and the the task here is now to take
these two audio clips each of them has a
different mixture of the two speakers
and the machine learning algorithm is
expected to output
two different two different waveforms
where the source the voices are
separated
right so all that you're feeding into
the algorithm
is just two clips you're not saying
you know there's no kind of supervision
telling you know
speaker one's y sounds like this or
speaker two's voice sounds like this
there's no supervision whatsoever
you're just feeding it two clips where
the clips have
mixed audio of two different speakers
and the uh
model outputs um the separated voices
so let's see if the audio works here
right that's you know from one
microphone there were two speakers
[Music]
right that's from another microphone
probably the
the the sound of one of the speakers was
a little louder and the second one
or uh vice versa and when you separate
them
[Music]
one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten
right so all what you gave the algorithm
was these two audio clips
and nothing else right just two wav
files and
it you know it analyzes the audio
waveforms
looking for structures and it's able to
separate the voices
with no supervision whatsoever
and you're going to be doing one of this
in your homeworks as well
it will not be two but actually a set of
five audio clips that are mixed together
and
you're given five different audio files
and you will implement
the uh the ica algorithm that you're
going to cover in the course and and
separate the audio into five you know
distinct distinct clips
and finally reinforcement learning so
here's an example of
reinforcement learning where the goal of
the algorithm is to control what's
called
what's commonly called the inverted
pendulum or the card pole so
imagine you have a stick and you're
trying to balance a stick on your hand
a vertical stick on your hand you know
and
we are trying to control this um
this card poll agent in order to keep
the stick that's placed on it
well balanced right so uh when you start
a learning algorithm from scratch so uh
this is episode so each trial is an
episode
when once the stick falls you start the
next episode and
for example this is episode zero it is
falling falling falling now it's episode
one falling again
episode two
scroll down episode three
alone and you you train this algorithm
you continue trying it for more episodes
and
eventually it will it'll get better um
i stopped the algorithm for for this uh
stopped at about
130h but if you let it continue it's
going to learn to
learn how to balance the card pole for
you know potentially indefinitely long
there you go oops i think
it it falls off the table or something
anyway so um
again this is going to be on your
homework as well you're going to you're
going to
write a reinforcement learning algorithm
that's going to learn
in a in a simulator like this how to
balance balance a stick on top of a
cardboard
yes question
so the question is uh for for uh those
who are watching uh the lecture on
online um is it necessary to have as
many number of audio clips as the number
of speakers
yes that's exactly right you need as
many number of audio clips as
the number of speakers
okay so that's about uh it for
the introduction so for
the rest of today
we will be
yeah so for the rest of today we'll be
covering um
doing a review of linear algebra uh in
case you you know it's been a while
since you took linear algebra
to brush you up and familiar familiarize
you with
the concepts that are more important for
this course and
in the next um next class we'll be doing
covering matrix calculus and and some
probability and statistics
um and from you know onwards we'll be uh
getting into actual machine learning uh
models yes questions
yep so uh the the uh question was
the um in unsupervised learning you're
you're just given a data set and asked
uh you know to
how to find structures in the data and i
also spoke about an example
uh with with the uh language translation
where a model was just given unpaired
mappings of
language and it still learned how to uh
map from each other
uh the answer to that is a little
technical let's take that offline you
know after the lecture you know
come up and we can talk about that
all right so i'm going to be assuming
all of you
are are familiar with um some basics of
linear algebra in the sense
all of you know what a matrix is know
what a vector is you know
what you can do with vectors and
matrices
so we'll be reviewing them but also i'm
going to be
assuming some familiarity from all of
you so first of all some notation
so what's a vector
right so um for the purposes of this
course
we will assume that a given vector let
us call it v
is an element of
r to the t now
let's let's let's let's uh make sure all
of us understand what what this means
right this means an element of you know
from set theory
so v is a vector it is an element of
this set
and this set is a d dimensional real
space
right so what's a d dimensional real
space so
this is imagine this is
the real line
and this is x y
z so this is an example this is
r 3 because there are three dimensions
right
so a vector is an element of a
d-dimensional
real space and vectors are
when we say it is an element it means it
is a point that lives in
this d-dimensional
real space vector can also be
represented
as
e1 v2
ed we generally write a vector generally
is
considered as a column vector we write
it as a column in this course
you can also write a row vector as v
transpose
it's going to be v
v d right so what what what do these
numbers mean
these numbers are basically the
coordinates of
this point
so this is v1
this length and this length is uh
we just write it here v1 v2
v3 right and
this point over here is is v
right similarly we we also have
a matrix
right so we write matrices as uh let's
call it a letter a so generally matrices
have
we use capital letters for vectors we
use small letters
and we say is member of
r m by n
right you can you can
interpret uh a matrix a as um
as an element living in an m by n
um dimensional real space what does that
actually mean
right so you can think of that as
so matrix is is a grid of numbers um
real valued numbers for the purpose of
this course
um through the course we we hardly ever
deal with complex numbers so um it's
going to be only real numbers
think of it as a m by n grid of real
numbers
and that's a matrix you can interpret
this
as n m n
column vectors of m dimension each right
or you can think of it as
m row vectors of n dimension each
right there is
a special matrix called the identity
matrix
which is ones along the diagonal and
zeros everywhere else i just write a big
zero to indicate that
all the individual cells are zero
you can also have a diagonal matrix
where
a diagonal matrix is one where
all the cells except the diagonal are
zeros
and these could be any value
something called a symmetric matrix
a symmetric matrix where
a equals a transpose
what is transpose
switching rows and columns exactly so a
transpose of a matrix
in this case um take the first row i'm
sorry the first column
and treat it as the row of the transpose
right and take the second row second
column and make it the second row and so
on
right the
the property that the transfer satisfies
is that a
i j equals a transpose
j i here i and j are the
uh row and column um
indices of of of a given matrix
so when you transpose it the row number
becomes the column number and the column
number becomes
the row number
the trace of a matrix
is the sum of the
of the diagonal of that matrix so take a
square matrix and sum up the diagonals
um and that that's the trace
let's look at some basic operations that
you can do with vectors
so if you have two vectors you can
you can kind of combine them in two
different ways right
so the first is called the inner product
so first this
so vector vector operations given two
vectors what can we do with them so the
first
is is the inner product
and um technically the inner product and
dot product
are distinct concepts but in this course
they're going to be the same so
the dot product
so one way to think of the inner product
is
if you have two vectors x comma
y both in
rd so in order to perform the inner
product
the two the two vectors have to be of
the same dimension
for example d and the inner product
is the sum over i equals 1 to
d x i y i
and this is also written as x transpose
y so this is the
the mathematical um representation of
the
dot product you could also think of
this as like this you think of
a vector written as a row vector another
vector written as a column vector
the two have to have the same dimension
and
when you perform the inner product you
get a scalar
right you feed in two vectors the output
is a single number right you you've lost
the angles or or the orientation of the
vectors once you perform
an inner product right
the other operation you can do with two
vectors
is the anybody
you can do the cross product uh the
cross product however is
not very interesting for us you also
have something called the outer product
right so the cross product and outer
product are different things right so uh
in cross product you
uh you you're given two two vectors and
you find a new vector that is
perpendicular to the plane in which the
two
two vectors are ah but here we're going
to talk about the
outer product
in the product and we have the outer
product
so in the outer product you can have x
in let's call it r
d and y in
r p right
so for the outer product the two vectors
need not have the same dimension
right but in a product they have to have
the same dimension and
um mathematically we write the outer
product as
x y transpose
right it could also you you could also
um
have a different outer product which is
y x transpose
in this case x transpose y and y
transpose x for the inner product was
the same
so you know you could you could switch
the order
but for outer products if you switch the
order
you get something which is a little
different
um the way to think of the outer product
um at least pictorially is
something like this okay
right so think of
vector one 2 so we have a column vector
and a row vector
right so in this case this
is d dimensional and this is p
dimensional
right
so with the inner product we took a row
vector a column vector and convert it
into a scalar
right but with an outer product what we
do is
you take each
each and every possible pairs of
elements from the row vector and the
column
for example take the first element from
the column vector and say the third
element from the row vector
multiply those two elements right and
that becomes
the first row third column
cell of this matrix so you take two
vectors and construct a matrix out of
them
right by pick the
pick the ith element from this vector j
element from this vector multiply them
and that becomes the ij element of
of of the matrix right so this this uh
for the outer product you don't need the
vectors to have the same dimension
and a matrix that you construct
from one row vector and one column
vector
is also called a rank one matrix
right why is it called rank one because
one way to think of it is it is made of
one
pair of row and a column vector right
so that makes it what also called as a
rank one matrix
right you could also for example
um two
rank one matrices add them up
so these together will give you
one bank one matrix add it with
another rank one matrix right
so the row call the the column vectors
have to be of the same dimension
the row vectors have to be of the same
dimension
but the two need not be the same
dimension right so if you know these two
have to be d dimension these two have to
be for example p
dimension here you get a rank one matrix
you get another rank one matrix
you sum them up element wise and you get
a
another matrix of rank
so you take two rank one matrices you
add them up
you get a rank two matrix so you take
two rank one matrices and you add them
up
you can you get a rank two matrix
assuming the vectors are
linearly independent right if the
vectors are linearly independent
you take two rank one matrices add them
up you get a rank two matrix
now what happens if
say we add k of them so 1
2 what's the rank of this matrix
rank k so the rank of this matrix
is actually going to be the
less than or equal to min of d
p and k so the rank of the matrix cannot
be bigger
than the smaller dimension of the matrix
right so by adding the rank one matrices
or you know uh
or linear adding linearly independent
rank 1 matrices or increasing the rank
of your
resulting matrix but you can only go up
as high as the smaller of the two
dimensions
yes question yes uh
we will i will define the rank uh for
now um
let's let's uh think of a rank as um
think of this as a sheet of paper like
you know think of this as a matrix
and you add more sheets of papers you're
increasing the rank of the matrix
you will precisely define what the rank
of a matrix is in
in a few minutes
and and just by looking at a matrix if
you're just given
a bunch of numbers of rows and columns
it's pretty much impossible to tell what
the rank
of that matrix is right it's
superficially you
you cannot just tell by looking at um um
looking at a matrix what its rank is
right it's it's like an inherent
property
there are you know simple cases if
you're given a diagonal matrix where
everything is zero southern diagonal yes
you can tell the rank but
in general just by looking at the values
of a matrix you cannot tell what
the rank of matrix is
ok so those are vector vector operations
lets look at some matrix vector
operations
right so um
in a matrix vec so um we went to what
vector vector operations the inner
product and the outer product
for the inner product you had to have
both the vectors of the same dimension
and you would get a scalar for an outer
product they could be of different
dimensions
and you've got to rank one matrix right
now let's look at
matrix vector operations so for a matrix
vector operations
first we're going to consider operations
where you have a matrix
let's call it a and
a vector call it x and this let's call
it
m by n and
this is n so a
belongs to r m by n
and x belongs to r n
right so this is um and and so a
x is now
of dimension
this one so how do you think about this
operation so first you can um
think of the matrix
as a set of rows
right so each row has n elements
right and the vector you're multiplying
with is a column vector
right and all you're doing is the inner
product right
take the first row get the inner product
with
the matrix and you get a scalar
right take the second row do the inner
product you get another scalar
and you're going to get as many number
of scalars as the number of rows you
have in the matrix
right so
so ax
rm you can write this as m by one but
you know
um we assume vectors are column vectors
so
if i write just you know in rm it you
know just assume it's it's a
m by one if you want to think of it that
way
another interpretation of uh matrix
vector
multiplication is
it is the same matrix except we are
going to think of them as columns
right m by n
this is n so this is a and this is x
so this has i'm just going to use
different symbols
let's assume you know there are three
elements um and
all right this has four so let's let's
assume this has four elements
and the uh n is four a is a
m by four matrix um and you're trying to
calculate a x the other interpretation
here is let me use some colors
so here we did inner products right here
what we're going to do is
pick the first element of of x
scale the first column of a
right and then pick the second element
of x scale the second column of a by
that number
by scaling i mean do an element-wise
multiplication of
of this number with all the elements
here you know just rescale it
and
pick the third element of x scale the
third column
okay and
and then you just um sum them up along
this way so sum up the scaled versions
right so ax
is again you know you're summing up uh
m dimensional column vectors that are
scaled by the corresponding
values in the vector and that's just
going to give you you know
and whether you do the operation this
way or this way you'll always end up
with the same
same right hand side right so that is
matrix vector
and then you have matrix matrix
so again for matrix matrix there are
kind of you know
two interpretations of how you kind of
visualize
uh the product of two matrices so let's
assume you have
two major six matrices m by k
times
k by n so it is important that
the the number of columns
of the first one and the number of rows
of the second one are the same
right and in interpretation number one
we'll go with the
inner product interpretation so you have
m rows of k dimensions each
and n columns of
k dimensions each right
the dimensions are matching of the row
and the column so
naturally we want to do the inner
product right now
take every pair of row and column vector
um
so that that gives you m times n so
any any row vector any column vector
perform the inner product and that
becomes the
cell value of the corresponding i throw
and j column
right so pick the say the second row
and the fourth column do the inner
product and that is the second row
fourth column of
of of your output matrix
so matrix multiplication essentially a
whole bunch of inner products that
you're doing concurrently
in parallel you can also um
the same operation m by k
k by n and in this case think of them as
right so now we have k
column vectors and k row vectors
right m and n are different so this is m
dimensional and this is n dimensional
but we have k of each of them
right now pick them pairwise
not all possible best but pick them
pairwise so first row and first column
i'm sorry first column and first row
do the outer product you get a rank one
matrix
right so you get a rank 1 matrix of
so this is column 1 from
the first matrix and row 1 plus
pick the second column and second row
column 1 and
row column 2 and row 2
right and add k of them
so column k and row k so the columns
come from the left matrix and the rows
come from the right matrix
and you add them up you get a
another matrix right and
the matrix that you calculate this way
or the matrix that you calculate this
way are going to be exactly the same so
they're just two different
interpretations of the same mathematical
operation
any questions so far yeah
yeah so um the question is um
should this be a rank one matrix um so
the the uh when you take a
a column vector and a row vector and
take the outer product this will be a
rank one matrix
and this is another separate rank one
matrix and this is another rank one
matrix
and when you add them up when you add k
of them you get a potentially
you know a min of you know m n and k
rank matrix
it will if if the rows and columns are
linearly independent it will not be rank
one
you're increasing the rank as as long as
you're taking linearly independent rows
and columns
but you cannot you cannot keep adding uh
matrices
rank one matrices and increase your rank
forever you have an upper bound which is
the smaller of the two dimensions of the
row or column
all right so
[Music]
there was another question of what the
rank was and before we get to that
let's see why do we need to learn linear
algebra for machine learning why is
linear algebra even relevant for machine
learning
so uh some of the um
some of the situations where we will end
up using linear algebra
you know through the rest of the quarter
is first
is
represent data
so suppose in a supervised learning
setting um your
let's say you want to predict uh the
price of the house and
the inputs that you are given are things
like you know the number of bathrooms
the number of bedrooms
you know the area etc um
you would then represent your training
data
as x as
you know
where each row x is is you it's also
called the design matrix where each row
is a is an example is a different
example
and the columns corresponds to what are
also called as features
uh for example uh this could be house
one house two house three house four
etcetera and this could be say number of
bedrooms
area number of bathrooms etc
and this is generally called a design
matrix so your design matrix
x is
most conveniently represented as a
matrix
similarly your supervision values the
actual house prices of those houses
is most conveniently represented as a
vector
right so just to represent your data it
is
convenient to use concepts from linear
algebra like matrices and vectors
right and then we're going to do a whole
lot of manipulation with these like you
know multiply this
you know um x vector with a you know
another parameter vector called theta
and so on and so on so we're going to be
using linear algebra for
representing our data and also doing
operations on them
another um situations where we will
need um matrices is going to be in
in probability to represent what's
called covariance matrices
you'll cover probability review tomorrow
and we will go over what
what a covariance matrix is so for
example uh covariance matrices
they are generally written as you know
they tend to be symmetric um symmetric
uh means
the matrix and its transpose are the
same
right and we're going to use a linear
algebra for
for calculus multivariate calculus
right so things like
gradients so gradients and
i'm expecting you know what a gradient
is so um
you um gradients tend to be vectors
right so you you would represent vectors
as
as as um column vectors
hessians hessians are matrices um
hessians are basically like you know
think of them as the second derivative
in the multivariate setting
um and and
um jacobians jacobians are derivatives
of
a vector valued output from you know a
vector-valued input
all of those can be so gradients
maybe vectors hessians
matrix matrix symmetric
jacobians
in the matrix and jacobian will likely
not be symmetric
uh and so forth and we're also going to
see uh
use linear algebra very liberally in
kernel methods
you're not expected to know what a
kernel method is i'm just listing it
here
um just so uh you know you know that you
know
learning linear algebra has uses in all
these
various scenarios right and by calculus
i also mean
you know in general optimization you
know given a loss function
um we need to minimize it right and and
uh
we're going to use gradients and
hessians um and
um so so on there right
so yeah so so linear algebra is is is
important and
it's very important that you are
comfortable
manipulating these concepts such as
matrices and vectors and you know
multiplying them taking inverses etc
any questions before we move on to
a few more interesting concepts
no questions
so we saw matrix vector multiplication
over here right so here's it like
let's do a geometrical interpretation of
so linear algebra is one field of
mathematics where it's very easy to
visualize things which makes it really
fun and
also kind of easy once you kind of get
the core intuitions right
so we saw the matrix vector
multiplication
uh so a let's let's call a matrix as a
it's in r m
by n and let's say you have a vector
x in rn
right now when you do a matrix vector
multiplication you get something called
ax right
and this is in r
m right so one way to
to think of ax is through these you know
row interpretation or column
interpretation right but
an even more useful way to think about
this is to
think of a as some kind of a function
right think of a as a function it's you
know you we've been looking at
the matrix as a set of numbers right so
stop thinking
of it as a set of numbers but think of
it as a function a function that takes
x as input and outputs you know
that vector now
let's assume you have we have a
in our three by three
right which means we have uh
it takes us input values from a
three-dimensional space
and its output is also
a three dimensional space
right now we are thinking of a as a
function
right who which takes us input
the inputs are vectors and the outputs
are also vectors right so x is a vector
ax is also a vector
they are in different dimensions yes
right so it takes as
input an n dimensional vector and
produces an output
which is an m dimensional vector right
so let us pick
some so assume this is the a which
which ah does the multiplication and
so these are let us call them
x axis y axis y axis
is three by three and let us say we
so this is a vector in you know this
is some x it lives in a three
dimensional space and it has
you know a column representation
right multiplied by a
right and lets say it maps it here
in the output space right
now let us take another vector let's
call it
and this is some other vector run it
through a it's going to give you a
different output
right so perhaps it comes here
and similarly you know take
a third third vector right through a and
it's probably going to come here
right so the what this picture is
representing is
you have this function a
right we don't think of it as you know
numbers anymore we think of it as a
function
for which we feed we we take some point
in the input space as the input
feed it into the function and it outputs
you know a new vector in in a you know
possibly a different dimensional space
in
this case it's three and three to make
the visualization simple
right now if a
is full rank which means its rank is
um is three in this case
right there is going to be a unique
mapping
between every point in the input to
every point in the output there's going
to be a one
you know one by one mapping one to one
mapping between every point in the input
to a corresponding point in the output
right now if a is such a matrix that
makes
such a one to one mapping possible a is
a full rank matrix
right now um so this is input space
and this is the output space
right now you could also imagine that
there exists
some other matrix call it b
right that takes these values as the
input
right say the red as the input
run it through b and it outputs
the original point over here right
now if a is a full rank matrix
then such a b will exist you know which
which does the reverse mapping
and this b is also called a inverse
right so a is the function that takes
that takes vectors as input and maps
them to some output
and as long as it is full rank there
will be there will be another matrix
which is the inverse of it which takes
this as the input and corresponds the
and outputs the original point as as the
output
right now this is in the case of full
rank matrix
now what happens if
a is not full rank
so this was
full rank
now here if a matrix is not full rank
it's technique called a rank deficient
right so again this is the input space
x axis
y axis z axis
similarly that is output space
x axis y axis z axis
right and
similar we have an a over here a is
again
in r 3 by 3
but let's assume this is a rank 2 matrix
right
right and this was a full rank machine
this was a rank 3 matrix so it could
uniquely map every point every other
point and you could go back through the
inverse
now if it is
ranked efficient what this means is
if the rank is two it means there
exists a two dimensional subspace
in the input space you know
so there exists a two dimensional
subspace
what is the subspace mean so
assume this is the ambient space is
three dimensional
assume this room to be the ambient three
dimensional space
any two dimensional place for example
this paper that extends
indefinitely in all along all directions
is a subspace that lives in this three
dimensional space right
now if if the rank of the matrix is
two you know and it is
a three by three matrix then in this
three dimensional ambient space there
exists
a two dimensional subspace that is
specific to this matrix
and that subspace must pass through the
origin
right and also a corresponding
subspace in the output
space which is also two dimensional
which is what makes it you know a rank
two matrix there is a two dimensional
subspace and a two dimensional subspace
again this also has to go through the
through the origin
and there exists a one-to-one mapping
between points
on this subspace to points on this
subspace
so
a point on the subspace may get mapped
here
another point over here make it map here
similarly a third point here you get
mapped here
right now these this subspace extends to
infinity in all directions
right in both in both the input and
output space
and a gives you a unique one to one
mapping
between elements in these subspaces
but a is a three by three matrix right
it's it's a function
um think of it as a function for which
you can feed
any input you know just because
a subspace exists for which a one to one
ah mapping exists
doesn't mean you know for example i may
take this point
that lives outside the subspace right
this is you know think of this as the
ambient three dimensional space this is
a two dimensional subspace what about
the point over here where the pen decide
it's not living in the subspace it's
outside the subspace
right take take such a point that you
know that doesn't live in the subspace
you can still feed this point as an
input to this function and it's going to
map it somewhere
right where but where will it map it to
right
the way to think about that is
any given point in the input you know
in the input space of a matrix can be
decomposed right
you can decompose x
into two parts one part
so let us assume this is x and x lives
outside the subspace you can decompose
this
x into two parts where one part lives
in the subspace and is in a way nearest
to the given x and another part
which is this residual from that nearest
point
to the actual point right which means
assume the origin is in that corner and
this is
a two dimensional subspace that kind of
passes through the origin
and we have a point over here this point
can be decomposed into two part into two
parts
this point is represented by a vector
that starts at the origin and ends at
this point you can decompose into two
parts
where one part lives strictly in the
subspace
and it extends all the way till it is
nearest to this point and a second part
which is a point that is perpendicular
to the subspace that originates from
that nearest point to this point right
it's like you know pythagoras theorem
you have
two two components which are at right
angles
and any vector can be decomposed into a
component that lies in the subspace and
a component that is strictly
perpendicular to the subspace
right and okay
i'm sorry what's the question
yes uh you you you can call it a a
resolution but
a more commonly used term is
decomposition so you decompose that
vector into two parts
right and these two parts when i mean
decomposition i don't
mean take the vector you know the and
split it into
you know a two dimensional versus a
three dimensional um um you know
what i mean is you know you should not
be confusing this
this uh decomposition as splitting it
into one part that lives in
uh the subspace versus another that's
not what we are talking about
right what we are talking about is you
know
x can be written as
i am going to use the word projection
over here so the projection of
x onto the subspace
plus the
the technical term over here would be
the
row space
plus projection on to
the null space
now what does that mean i mean we saw
two terms over there a row space and a
null space
now row space is actually the subspace
which
which gets mapped bijectively to the
corresponding you know
the output subspace right this subspace
in the input space
right for which the bijection exists is
also called the row space
and it's called the row space because it
is made up of
precisely those points which can be
represented as linear
combination of the rows of a
right yes question
are all projections orthogonal i'll come
to that in a moment yes
um so um the row space is made up of
all points that that can be represented
as
linear combinations of the rows of a and
it is precisely that subspace
for which a bijection exists between you
know the the output space and
and the input space
so this is called the row space and this
is called the column space
right it's also called like um the range
of it's also called the range or you can
think of it as the columns and this is
precisely
those the set of all points which can be
represented as
linear combinations of the columns of a
right
now the the point over here
which did not exist in the row space
we said can be represented as the sum of
two
components we can decompose it as the
sum of two components
one component that lies in the row space
and is nearest to
x and another component which is you can
call it you know what's left or the
residue
right which is orthogonal to
your row space and the question was
uh is the projection always
perpendicular to the space onto which
you're
projecting it to yes the answer is yes
so the
the way you want to think of it is let's
assume this is the subspace
this is a two dimensional subspace in
this ambient three-dimensional space
and you have some point over here you
know where this you know
black pen is and you want to project it
onto the space onto the subspace
now the the the way you
do the projection is search all the
points that exist in the subspace
calculate the distance from that space
from that point
to this point and choose the point that
that has the smallest distance
right that point is the projection of
the the the point having the smallest
distance from this point
is the projection of this point onto the
subspace and
the the line connecting the true point
to the projection point
is always going to meet at an angle of
90 degrees it's always going to be
perpendicular to the subspace itself
and it's it's kind of intuitive right so
um
um in the subspace you know um
the point that is nearest on this on
this plane
to this point is going to be the one
that is like directly below it and so
that line is always going to be you know
perpendicular
does that answer your question okay yes
question
subspaces always pass through the origin
by definition they pass through the
origin
because this is always going to be some
linear combination of the row or the
columns and the linear combination can
have be just zeros you know just
zero times column one plus zero times
column two so the origin is always part
of
both the input subspace and the output
subspace
yes question
yeah so the question is what is row
space so row space is
precisely the set of all points that can
be represented as linear columns of the
rows
right so column space is the set of all
points that can be represented as linear
combination of the columns of
of a which means the set of all points
that you can obtain by
multiplying some vector with that matrix
right
and according to this definition it is
some linear combination of the columns
of of a and you know um you take the
transpose and you get the row space
yes
right so the question is are the
subspaces
so the question is are the points of
different colors
are they the rows or columns of
the matrix a is that the question so
good question thank you for asking that
question so the points that i'm
choosing over here right have nothing to
do with
in the sense they need not
be either a row or a column of
a right the points that lie
on this subspace
can be represented as some linear
combination of the rows of a
right what it means is
one of the so if a has has has three
rows there will be three points
in the subspace which corresponds to the
three rows of a
it has to it has to lie there because
you know um
what i mean by that is let's assume a
has three rows
this is a it has three rows and this
is the subspace obtained by linear
combinations of these three rows
which means one of the combinations
could be one zero zero
right 1 times the first row plus 0 times
the second row plus 0 times the third
row
must align the subspace right which
means
first row exists at some point in the
subspace
does that make sense
yeah so ah yeah so that's that's the
uh row space and any given x
now what happens you know back to the
question of
what happens if we take some x that does
not exist
in the in the row space of x
and you multiply it through and multiply
by a what happens and this is where the
the decomposition you know helps us find
an answer
so a of x
is going to be a of
i am going to abuse notation and write
it as
x r plus
x n where it is this is the projection
of x onto the row space
and this is the residue
right and this
the direction in which the residue lives
is also called the null space of a which
means
any point that lives in the null space
of a will always
get mapped to 0 in the output space
right that's called the null space of a
so
any point in the input space can be
broken down into
two components a component that lives in
the row space and a component that lives
in the null space
right and a of x you know you can
represent it as
you know the row space component plus
the null space component
and because a is a linear function
you can write this a of x r
plus x
n right and this
is 0 because you know you're feeding
this this
is a vector in the null space you
multiplied by a
it always goes to 0
right and so this is just a of
x r so the the operation you want to
think
in your mind is given any point in the
input space which may or may not lie in
the row space
when you multiply it by multiply it with
a
what happens is effectively you project
that space onto the row space
and transfer that
you know and find the corresponding
output of that projection
right so it essentially means
this operation is effectively just
pruning out anything that's outside the
row space of you know from from the
input
find the projection onto the row space
and and carry forward that point onto
the output space
right so this concept of projection is
super important
we're gonna um we're going to come
across
this concept this this projection again
when we when we uh do linear regression
right so what's what's uh technically
how do we calculate the projection
right here i just represent it as some
abstract function
called projection and here i used you
know the
the resulting vector after you do the
projection but how do you actually
calculate the projection
right and that's not too hard either so
so projection we'll start with the
simplest case
the simplest case where we have
considered you have a vector
let us call this v
some vector and
you have another vector let us call it
b right there are two different vectors
and now we want to project
b onto the direction
onto the subspace spanned by v right
v is a vector and it induces a subspace
and that subspace is a one dimensional
subspace
which is made up of all linear
combinations of the vector b
which means take b multiplied by 2 you
get
you take v you know 2 v is part of that
subspace 1
you know 0.5 v is part of that subspace
minus v is part of that
subspace so this entire line is the
subspace
spanned by v by the vector v and now we
want to project the vector b
onto the subspace right
and how do we do that for that there is
um
for for a given v there is something
called the projection matrix
so the projection matrix of v
is v v transpose
over v transpose v
we'll decipher this in in in a minute
now this is a projection matrix which
means
you take this matrix and
take any other vector right it could be
this vector it could be this vector
right and if you multiply b
by this matrix the resulting point
is going to be the projection of
projection of of b onto that onto the
subspace
spanned by v now why is that the case
that's the case because let's look at
what's happening here
i'm going to rewrite this as so v
v transpose b
over v transpose b and this
is the same as
v over norm of
v
v transpose b
right so v transpose v is the same as
the square
of the length of v its that is the norm
square of
v and that um
so this is the square of the length i
distribute one of the length to this and
one of the lengths to that
right so when you divide a vector by its
length you are effectively
rescaling it into a unit length vector
right so now i am going to call this
say v tilde
v tilde transpose b
where v tilde is a vector along v
that has length equal to 1 maybe this
point over here
is v
right you can you can pick
any vector along this along
on the subspace and it's always going to
result in the same
projection matrix because you're
rescaling it by the length so it doesn't
matter which
which specific vector you chose in the
subspace we rescale it by the length
come back to v tilde and the projection
matrix is v tilde v tilde transpose
now this
write it as v tilde times
v tilde transpose b
right and this we know is the
when when you take the inner product
between a unit length vector
and any other vector
it's going to give you the the
the length of the projection of this
vector onto the unit length vector
right so the
if v transpose is v tilde is is
some unit length vector you take any
other
vector b the inner the inner product
between two
vectors where one of them is unit length
is going to be the magnitude of the
other vector
along the direction of of the unit
length vector right
so this is going to be
the length
of the projection of b along the
dimension of v
and then this is just some scalar you're
rescaling v tilde
by some scalar again right so this
this is the projection matrix
of some vector v where
the projection matrix projects the input
that is fed into the projection matrix
onto the subspace spanned by it
is this clear any questions
now what happens if instead of
one vector v we give you we we have a
collection of vectors
a bunch of column vectors for example
we have let's say you know
we have a subspace spanned by the
a collection of three row vectors now
if these are the vectors on to which
ah whose subspace onto which we want to
project x we follow something
very similar to this
in space in in in place of v
instead of this being a vector
we will have a matrix where the matrix
here
is will be some matrix
x whose columns
are vectors which make up the subspace
onto which we want to project it
right in this case it it was
a vector it was a subspace with just one
vector
but if you want to project b onto a
subspace
spanned by multiple vectors right
then in place of v we are going to use
some matrix x whose columns
are precisely those
you know a set of vectors which make up
the subspace yes question
they need to be linearly independent by
definition uh because those are you know
to make up a subspace you know you need
a set of linearly independent vectors
right
so um take take
this some set of linearly independent
vectors
from that subspace right and
wherever there is we just plug in x so
we are going to get x
this looks different from this and
that's because
in v transpose we was a scalar and you
could
you can divide something by a scalar
right but x transpose x
is is going to be a matrix and you
cannot divide something
by a matrix it's not even a meaningful
operation how do you even go about doing
it right so the
the the right way to think about
this is to rewrite this as
v
right so i just rewrote this as v
v transpose v inverse v transpose which
is uh which is the same
and it is this form that can generalize
into a matrix form right so
the projection matrix for a set of
columns
is is this and we're going to come again
come on come across this concept again
when we do linear regression so
remember that yes
i could have put it anywhere yeah
so the question is um why did we put the
x transpose x
inverse in the middle rather than to the
left or to the right right
so um it's i mean the the answer is
is um is
is i don't know if this is a
satisfactory answer but this is the only
thing that makes sense
if you you know no other position will
match the dimensions right so
x is m by n
x transpose x or x transpose x inverse
is n by
n and x transpose is
n by m so in a way that's the only place
where it kind of fits
in order to kind of multiply things
i know that's not a satisfactory answer
but you know that that's the only
operation that kind of makes sense
right so this this this um
this concept of what happens when you're
this whole idea of of projecting things
and
and finding a point for which you know
uh
bijections exist and moving over is is
is going to be a recurring theme it's
it's it's something you want to kind of
understand really well right any given
uh for a given matrix a which is not
full rank
there exists subspaces in its input and
output space
and the the dimension of the subspace is
going to be equal to the rank of the
matrix
and and
whenever you multiply a vector from the
input space what you are effectively
doing
is projecting that vector onto the row
space that the input
subspace for which a bijection exists
and then carry forward that point on to
the
output dimension which also means that
now if we have a point
that lives outside the subspace in the
in the output space
and we want to find out what
point in the input space will give me
this as the output which is effectively
we are asking the question
what is a inverse right that does not
exist
there for no point in the input space
can we reach a point that lives outside
the the the column space
right this point is unreachable
and and in when when we when we
cover linear regression we're going to
ask exactly this question when we have a
point that
is not unreachable you know what are we
going to do about it how are we going to
find an input that you know
that's that's basically linear
regression and which we'll cover on on
on friday
but this this this whole idea of of
subspaces
you know row space null space
decomposition
uh uh bijection the these are things you
want to you want to
kind of digest it well you know um and
absorb them really well
let's see we have about eight more
minutes
all right so uh we might be able to
squeeze in this one
so
we might run over a little over time
today but i'll try to wrap up as much as
possible and we can continue the rest
all right so here we saw
kind of a visual representation of what
a the matrix a does to the input and
output
now next we're going to limit ourselves
to only square matrices
which means the input and output spaces
have the same dimensions
and for the purpose of visualization
we're going to only consider
let's say a three-dimensional space
right now in this diagram we have two
different
of two different pictures for the input
space and the output space
but now because a is symmetric i'm sorry
a is
is a square matrix we're going to
overlay the input and output space onto
the same space
right so here the input space and output
space are
are being overlaid here
now let's ask the question
this you know
now let's ask the question we saw what
happened uh for you know
pick you know choose some points you
know run it through a you get an output
output point now what happens if we take
the unit sphere around the origin
by unit sphere i mean
[Music]
just the points on the surface of the
unit sphere think of it as a soccer ball
that is centered on the origin and you
take every point on the surface
run it through a you get a corresponding
output point for every
you know input point of of of the soccer
ball
right how would the resulting shape look
right so that is going to look as an
ellipsoid its its you know almost like
an ellipse
so that's going to be
right so what what what exactly happened
here
we it's a three dimensional input and
output space
we started with the input
as we didn't have one input but we had a
collection of points as inputs and that
collection was precisely those points
that live on the surface of
a unit sphere and
let's say we we took this point in the
input space
run it through a we got a corresponding
out point
and that point is say this one right so
every point
on the input surface maps to some point
on the output surface of that shape
right we could have done this with any
input shape but you know
sphere is easy to kind of analyze right
now similarly um you do it
for another point
let's say this point and let's say that
maps here
and let's say we take what color do we
alright
green and let's say we pick
this point and that maps here okay
now
we saw what what what happens when you
when we uh take some shape
for example a sphere and run it through
a instead of thinking of
uh um running a point through a now
imagine running
of you know a full shape through a which
which essentially means you're running
every point
in that shape through a and calculating
the output point which
you know which will be some other shape
so now uh think of a as
as taking as a shape as input and
outputting a different shape as the
output
right if the shape is some unit sphere
around
is the unit sphere around the origin the
output is going to be
an ellipsoid right now
this ellipsoid assuming a is
also symmetric
right will have
essentially just two things so first of
all so this was the input
this was the output this one which means
there were
two operations being done here one is
there is a change in magnitude so the
magnitude came down a little bit
and there is a change in direction right
a did essentially
like you know effectively two things
a change in direction and a change in
magnitude
now there are going to be some points
along you know some points on the unit
sphere
for which the only change is going to be
a change in magnitude and no change in
direction
right and those are your eigenvectors
for a full rank
three by three matrix there are going to
be three eigenvectors
right and this is going to be one of
them
and if it is symmetric those
eigenvectors are going to be
perpendicular
oh sorry used a wrong color i shouldn't
have used
that's it so this is going to be one
eigenvector and there's going to be
another eigenvector
which will map this point on the input
to a point on the output where the only
thing that changes
is the magnitude and not the direction
yes question
so does it necessarily have to have
three eigenvectors
so it will have three eigenvectors
however
some of the eigenvalues may be zero i'm
going to come come to that right
so so this is going to be you know
eigenvector number one
for which the the scaling is the maximum
right and the eigenvalue is the the the
ratio
of the length of the input vector
and the length of the output vector so
if the output vector
is is stretched a lot along the eigen
eigenvector
then you have a large eigenvalue right
and
if if if the eigenvector
is is uh shrinking the point closer to
the origin then the eigenvalue is you
know
less than one if it is bigger than the
original point it's greater than one
your your point may also get reversed in
direction in which case your eigenvector
is negative
right now that's that's the eigenvector
and um the eigenvalues is the ratio of
the
output to the input
magnitude it may so happen that
when you take the
the unit sphere or the soccer ball as
the input and field
at the output the output may not be an
ellipsoid
but it may be a flat ellipse
which means you lost a dimension it got
kind of
smooshed into a two-dimensional ellipse
instead of
having a rigid three-dimensional
ellipsoid shape now that means
the eigen value along the third
eigenvector was zero
right so along along the third
eigenvector you know all the lengths
kind of
got mapped to zero is that does that
make sense
so now the a question was asked earlier
on
now what is the what's the meaning of
the rank of a matrix
so the rank of a matrix is precisely
equal to the number of non-zero eigen
values
right if the if the matrix
so this is in in in a square matrix
setting if a matrix has full rank then
it means
a a unit sphere will always come out
as some kind of an ellipsoid
with the same number of dimensions if
your rank deficit
the ellipsoid that comes out may have
lost a few dimensions